met the Queen I have yes here you are
getting is Mb you got I got there me
okay so nobody knows right yeah did you
know anything does she know anything
about racing i turn one down I mean it
wasn't strictly off of it I just thought
I'd nip it in the bud pool is up and
said I'm not interested they're the
kings did the Queen know anything about
Formula One she actually did when she
was talking to me there and she saying
we watch you but the best thing is I got
invited back I could get later for lunch
you can impress her the group that was
about as about eight of us and we I
turned up after the Brazilian Grand Prix
came back and walked in saw the the
seating plan and I was sat right next to
her so I was kind of excited you thought
you read yeah it was like yeah so I sat
down and she was to my right and I
started to talk to her and she's like um
she's like no you you you speak that way
first and I will speak this way and I
come back to you if you spoke to the guy
she of cards like me it's like I don't
have your questions
don't be the woman from that charity now
Lisa spoke to the guy next to her for
like five five minutes and then she
spent the rest of time talking to me yes
you wanted it was really really cool but
now you know Oba should say you and you
got yo P now who gave you yours Charles
Charles here Charles and now the OBE of
course can I bet you can guess oh maybe
you can guess what was the tabloid
headline when you and McGregor obi-wan
Kenobi will be Eddie yes yes oh
yeah OBE it writes itself
I liked it I really liked it when you go
when you go there wait first of all I
got on the I I went with my wife and my
two middle kids and we got in the tip we
got a taxi and I got in the taxi
Owen Buckingham Palace please and the
driver just mooned for the rest of the
time you know he said what have you got
a special day is it now went well
actually I'm getting I'm being given an
OBE today with my little kids I was all
proud of myself and hopefully them for
me and yeah and he went and oh yeah we
have to part they don't even let us out
of the car for a pee more he swore in
front of my little girls and mourned the
entire journey it's just like concrete
you and don't let him spoil your day
don't here you are in your kilt on the
day yeah it was really great and when
you go in you have to separate from your
guests and they go through to the hole
and then you spend the time up in this
big room with all of these amazing
people different people from all walks
of life you know a lot of servicemen and
women people from all the different
forces but also some strickler's a man
there and we old man in a kilt - I went
over to speak to him he was getting an
OB or an MB for services - bagpipe music
I mean I don't say
so this is about me
over RT twice
very Oh Liz you're older that's okay
we lady services to motorcycle-riding or
something
you know lady yes make it what face this
is seven if you say something very rude
what have you you've got one know what
oh how am I going to get oh yeah yeah
got it yeah
26 and I don't have a driver's license
I've been good to know what do you what
how does a man not have a driving me mad
about this they said that they have
reduced your part in the film to a
non-speaking role animation